lights camera action I think I want to
try to do a Potter pass you what what's
bad well I talk about what I do during
the day and maybe conversations because
I never heard that term so what do you
put it on the Internet
yeah so bad I don't have it I never
heard that name again the podcast pot
can Pioche that's funny yo D CA est all
right I never heard that term this is
the mild Adventures of Fred Stoller and
I have a very special guest Murray I'm
gonna give his name Murray Langston but
we're gonna start with a little game
Murray with amber tozer beside me
because she doesn't know who a lot of
people are right yeah but it's already
figured out you're corny as hell I know
she looked at me like weirdly like but
she was undressing me with her eyes
that's embarrassing why would she do
that you know I'm an old guy why would
she do they don't know she can't figure
amber out but trying I'm so basically
this is uh this is let me explain amber
to you a little bit okay I'm very
excited that we did I notice your
nipples are very hard yeah me too oh I
forgot the bell like right I interrupt
to my semi underwear hold on okay so so
to give you an idea of how amber is she
we this is a special announcement we did
a first vine together and I'm very
excited it already has 12,000 loops and
my other is like I'm looking at some of
my other as they they just have to bail
this is the Bell 2000 loops 2000 for me
all right so I was so excited and we're
at farmers market
- well Freddie you know 4000 loop she
goes that's because I have 50,000
Twitter followers and he's good at
JibJab so she she made it so her and
maybe it is where you guys make like 15
20 thousand dollars off that and that is
we make not as much as we make off this
which is the water over water okay so we
want to play a little game I get the pry
kid to tell the truth mixed up with um
what's my line where she gets five
guesses one-word answers it's obviously
my line isn't that something about
cocaine or something ready texting what
she wants to leave she texts this is
this is the earliest she's ever done it
we're like Marie's a great guide our
woman depends what I wear but we don't
have to go right now
so don't don't yell at him too much B's
old means sometimes that's why you
brought Mary so Sherry's here say hi
Mary
so we brought his daughter so amber
can't be too mean to you that's right
thank you yeah yeah well you never
yelled at a guy in front of his daughter
did you yeah okay she gives a great
massage but no biting she bites she
bites a little bit my buttocks are still
tingling all right okay five now
obviously we're what kind of wearing
show business did I first fall in love
with this guy to give you a hint
I love I used to star in porn I was a
stunt man in porn films actually if you
wanted I did King Kong plays ping pong
when his ding dong in Hong Kong all
right where do you don't need to go
there where where did I what kind of
genre think that I first did he get fame
from did you really first meet me in the
bathroom but you met him you met him I
met him after I was a fan of his was
very exciting because we talked about
this on other [ __ ] I did a morning table
at the farmers market which you came too
late for we're comedians talk and stuff
you have one or maybe I don't just go
have it at Jerry's deli what
Johnny Doc John Mendoza that's been
years yes that's right yeah I think no I
met you at the improv no it was a paid
toy
I remember now you're calling under and
I was crawling under we hit heads and
we've been friends ever since back in
the old days during the play toilet day
so where did he get his notoriety from
well now I know it sort of through
comedy yes but a specific place he broke
out in in it I'm breaking out right now
as a matter of fact Mary okay never mind
go out where did I break out from what
was my talk close to the mic oh all toys
were gone you still think dad's weird
huh I have to tell you I have to confess
something
what because you told me not to go to
your Facebook page to see who it was but
a question I accidentally saw it who he
was and I know where you were he was the
unknown comic on the gong show yeah and
now to set up for people today why he's
so exciting back when I was a teen 7ds
did they didn't have like Hulu and you
know cable and Amazon to the few shows
that were on was a big deal yeah and
there's the gong show and I had the 72
seminal because that's when I was at the
pristine and trying to figure out what
to do with my life so I love Mary
Hartman the Bob Newhart show the gong
show and he was the unknown comic he
would put a bag over his head and do
corny jokes and insult Chuck Barris and
he became famous from it and I loved him
so that you were a regular well I did a
hundred and fifty of those gong shows
during that that time there's four or
three or four years unless you were a
judge a lot of being a judge and then
they did a nighttime version of it but
but that was I mean not before that I
was in show business
- yeah well go into that story but how
did you how did you get how did you get
the gig what Ellis story the gong show
how you re first of all because I just
read his books I'm cheating a little bit
yeah but you now the thing I don't
understand
you didn't come to LA to make it as a
comedian but will you always this corny
kind of doing all these puns like how
could you say you didn't want to be a
comedian when all you do is make jokes
no I feel like I was grown up on Jerry
Lewis I just like it was a fanatical
Jerry Lewis fan and I and and I wanted
somehow to do what he was doing which
was you know being movies and stuff like
that but you know I was very naive
coming from Canada and so when I got
here I mean the thought of stand-up
never I mean getting in front of a crowd
telling jokes that was like just way too
beyond what I thought I could do so but
I want to be an actor and that's what a
comedic actor yeah that's all that's
what are you a you would like me very
skinny
yeah very thin and what my the first
thing I did was Rowan & Martin's
laugh-in and because I was skinny that
seat this is you have to took closer to
micro CEO Kim oh yeah it was Rowan &
Martin's laugh-in you probably don't
remember amber's like what are you 11
tall yeah so she wouldn't remember you
remember oh yeah it was a big big big
show it was like political and they had
all these people that broke out of it
Lily Tomlin Goldie Hawn Ruth Buzzi my
dear friend but Tiny Tim made it as
tiptoe through the tulips okay guy and
sang tiptoe and I ended up on the gunk I
mean on the laugh-in show also was my
first gig I was working at Universal
Studios as a computer operator but I got
on on laugh-in and doing my impression
of a fork
I'd actually did that in there why'd you
just put your arms up and yeah I was
really really thin really thin back
there and that's all I did was go on
like that and and so ah but I ended up
doing three or four impressions I did a
grandfather clock and I think the first
man on the Sun or something like that
I did three or four of them that they
wrote for me back in those days but yeah
that was my first job was was rolling on
Martin's laughing and I thought wow this
thing I'm gonna be a huge star after a
Tiny Tim made it big but it didn't do
nothing for me so I went back to you
know working and eventually got on this
I worked in a shoe store I worked in
issues as you see Haslam but that was
during a miniskirt craze which is not a
bad job back there you know yeah and I
was a kid yeah it was fun but yeah I was
actually selling shoes at JC Penney when
I when I got the job on the sunny
so wait next thing backtrack a little
bit you so you started going to comedy
clubs you decided what made you decide
to try to stand up and you picked a
black guy because you knew there was no
black and white comedy team correct yeah
yeah that's absolutely - yeah well what
happened well when I realized I wasn't
going anywhere after the fork and again
there was a fork in the road yeah I
could do it in this Korea see Mary
warning fork in the road going to back
to Jerry Lewis I went well I want to be
like another Jerry Lewis then I thought
well then he did Dean Martin and Jerry
Lewis I said I gotta find myself a
partner but before Freeman III worked up
with a guy
jatin named Jack Jack and Marie we call
herself Jack Moran okay I remember the
guys last Jack Jack Jack store was his
name Jack Star so he formed a comedy
team called Jackie Marie and there was a
little place on sets I called Canopus
right next to the body shop right next
door which is that one sushi place
but body shops not there anymore no the
little road next to her - it's all
owners called Conoco something amber I'm
more lame than usual but so I I they
were paid to know that oh yeah they're
paying actually or a hamburger and night
to work there this is before the comedy
story and a couple of guys named Cheech
and Chong were working there so I so we
started working together me Jack and
Marie and Cheech and Chong and a bunch
of other actors were all working this
place for a hamburger at night that was
for about six eight months and then I
went over to red foxes a nightclub me
and Jack didn't last long
because he you know didn't really find
it and he wanted a cheeseburger
yeah of hamburger wasn't it was tired he
WA he went a full grown meal so I went
to red foxes nightclub red fox out of
nightclub T I'm old when I think back to
these days La Cienega
we're guys like Flip Wilson the
temptations everybody was hanging out at
that joint at the time and that's why I
met Freeman the this the black guy ended
up teaming up with and so we got we
opened up for we ended up opening up for
Redd Foxx during those years me and
Freeman doing a bunch of really dirty
material but it was funny stuff
and then and then at red foxes club we
got spotted by an agent who ended up
putting us on the Sonny and Cher show
you probably heard of Sonny and Cher
amber she only heard of sheer you only
heard this year yes they passed away
yeah yeah here well so anyways the next
for now so I was telling shoes during
that entire period well au is selling
shoes while you were on the Sonny and
Cher no no well no while I was doing the
cano pose and red fox nightclub and then
that once I got on the Sonny and Cher
show I stopped I quit my job selling
shoes that's all right the Wiggles are
singing oh yes she pushed a button so I
right
so next four and a half years I had a
job on the Sonny and Cher show as one of
the regulars and that was like amazing
to me then it was four years what do you
do what a half years I clean toilets
yeah no I was one of the regulars who
were fighting [ __ ] awesome we did
character acting stuff teri garr you
remember the actress she was also he was
the one female regular and then there
was a Freeman King because they signed
both of us and a guy named Ted Ziegler
Billy Van they're all gone
Friedman's contents God Billy fans gone
I'm around cher is around we're the only
two left except for Teri Garr yeah and
she's struggling a little struggle yeah
Wow but those that we were the cast of
the Sonny and Cher show for four and a
half years I was quite a thing to go
from you know selling shoes to laughing
and who was some of the people that
would come by and you'd be in sketches
with where you did you get to your dream
of like Jerry Lewis that was the big
thing for me
they said well they just said one day
guess who we got starring next week
Jerry Lewis and I like course freaked
out and ended up working with him on he
ended up getting on the Sonny and Cher
show three or four times so what was it
like to meet the guy that made you want
to be in this business was sort of like
meeting you the first time I went home
is that really friend
same name is Fred Willard digitally yeah
coincidence I don't think so but no it
was it was phenomenal you know what's so
unusual I'm moving in as my daughter who
we just talked about my older daughter
Maya who has a number we're gonna try to
find the song and play some of it yeah
but she this is because I was talking
with her the other day the fact that I
was laughing ah you know crazy about
Jerry Lewis and then I ended up
working with him and my daughter was
crazy at ten nine ten years old over
Britney Spears and like ten years later
she was Britney Spears background singer
on three of her album Wow and even today
is weird like she's getting ready to go
to Korea on a little tour hopefully the
the south yeah the military bases which
is coincidence because I did the
military bases as a committee he was
with Pat Paulsen see he Murray was
Canadian and to be an American citizen
he left show business so much you
enlisted in the Army during Vietnam you
didn't know there was Vietnam wasn't
that I loved
it's just that was the only way I could
figure how to come to the States
you know how was it I was a kid and I
went how am I gonna get into the States
I didn't know how so I figured well I'll
join the military and you know and but I
didn't know was I had no clue that there
was a Vietnam when I joined but it
turned out there was and and I spent you
know four years in the Girl Scouts
Broken Hill twice no but I spent my four
years on the veteran guys so I can I'm a
vet I can work on your dogs or cats or
anything no I I spent my time in the
military but totally uh you know not
realizing that I was I mean when I
joined the older people would remember I
mean I joined I put me on this aircraft
carrier next thing I know I'm in the
Cuban blockade you know that Cuban
Missile Crisis missile and you've got do
I want to be in show business this is
you know but but again I had no idea I
was just a young kid wanting to go to
Hollywood and for me that was easiest
way how he Mendel did a little bit
better easier yeah wow yeah how did he
get into well he did clubs and Yuk Yuk's
and probably got a sponsor like noir
McDonald who was here last week excuse
me a lot of comedian excuse you know
maybe later but not right now
so wow so you you so you broke in to all
these things another thing that's
interesting amber wasn't here but we had
great character actor Robert Foster
from Jackie Brown and he used to hang
out at Schwab's which is no Hollywood
history and you were saying you did so I
hung out there a lot back in those who
was some of the actors and stars
you know Sally Maura was Lenny Bruce's
mother sure yeah she was she practically
lived there and a lot of comedians like
Jackie Gail Joey Rojas from I mean just
a whole well I loved movies about
Hollywood in Sunset Boulevard I love
this scene where they're all hanging out
and Schwab's and waiting at the phone
for a call so what was the call you got
there well you couldn't there was no
that was the Sonny and Cher show it was
like freaky you know yeah because I we
Freeman and I when we were seeing at red
foxes Club and we went down to addition
for these for these producers Chris
beard and Allen Bly who produced the
Sonny inertia which coincidentally were
writers on the laughing show when I got
laughing they I went to edition totally
naive you know I called it to story I
just was naive didn't know nothing about
show business didn't know you're not you
you can just call a producer Laughlin
was the biggest television show in the
country so I want to get on when I saw
Tiny Tim made it so I just said well how
do I called up NBC and I said can I talk
to the producer of laughing and they
said just a minute and all of a sudden
this guy you know a Paul George
sponsored slaughter I got on said yeah
what do you want I said yeah I a tiny
Tim was on your show I was like to get
on your shoes oh sit really what do you
do I said well I'm working on this
impression of a fork he said okay watch
come down tomorrow morning is there you
know so that's actually how it happened
how it might got my first job just naive
so I went down that morning and they
brought me into a room with a bunch of
writers and these two producers of the
Sonny and Cher show Chris Bearden Alan
Breck we're just writers on the laughing
show and I did this for and they all
just looked at me like yeah well I have
to stand up and then the microphone
would get caught my in my leg and but I
base I just stood up I was very very
thin you know no mustache didn't just
like that we just put my and the funny
thing is after show aired which was huge
I actually walked around the street like
this hoping people would recognize me I
yeah but anyway so leading onto that so
while was so what I ended up going years
later to the addition for the Sonny and
Cher show me and Freeman it was the two
writers the two guys who were from
laughing were laughing they said weren't
you the guy that did the
fork on laughs and years later and all
of a sudden they're producing this onion
share show and again we had nothing but
really filthy material Freeman and I
doing sketches we just did sketches we
didn't you know and so we edition and
they just looked at us and we left
they're thinking they know chance
they're gonna hire us but again we go
back to the beginning of the story I was
at Schwab's and Freeman calls me there
knowing I was there all the time and the
phone rings hey Murray you got a phone
call in Freeman says he's yelling on the
phone we got the job we're gonna be
understudy chair show and I'm screaming
and I'm yelling everybody know that
excitement yeah that's Schwab's
drugstore yeah well yeah I was much
better than getting like a text yes I'm
still trying to figure out how to do
texts yeah I miss my rotary phone oh
yeah I remember when numbers were like
ro9 with what things I'm so old I
remember this before this is area codes
area code that's well we have area codes
here no I'm been sick before oh yeah it
was a different world yes it was so but
that's what happened the Schwab story in
and end up on the sun-eater show for
four and a half years and then I ended
up taking that money and I bought a
nightclub cuz after the Sonny and Cher
show folder had I bought I started my
own nightclub called showbiz where guys
like Michael Keaton started Mike but his
name was Michael Douglas back at my club
Debra Winger was one of my waitresses
Wow and you dated her right yes yeah
this guy I have a little resentment cuz
I'm reading your book you've been with
so many waitresses and beauty stars and
all right you decide I did I did okay
thirty Seconds day but they cost me a
lot of money they wouldn't do it with me
for free right yeah yeah who else did
your club that you owned oh yeah so who
Gallagher started out there boy breakin
is watermelon at my place first place he
did it he actually came from Florida he
actually was with it
Jim Jim Jim was a guy a big singer
Jim Stanford Stafford I don't like
spiders and snakes fighters the snakes
right yeah and my girl bill yeah my girl
- shipstead well him and Gallagher we're
like best buddies and and Jim actually
who was a big star then call me came
into my club one day just walked in my
looks I'm saying hey can I do a show
here I just he was getting when I do a
variety show in LA and I'm one of the
network's and he said and can I bring my
buddy and guy he does this watermelon
thing to my club and and they did a
business before The Comedy Store was
your room before there was a lot of
clubs not really it was right about the
same accomplished or had already been
open a couple years
another thing we historical with me is I
was there the day to Comedy Store open I
was actually in the club to date you
know with some of the comics Letterman
Jimmy Walker I'm gay no those guys
weren't around then Letterman actually
started at my club - yeah he because he
had an apartment right down the street
from me on like a block away so let him
in
used to come and work in my club all the
time when he was just starting out but
the comedy star had already been open
about two years when I opened up my
place so and I only have my place for a
couple of years because I didn't know
what the hell I was doing you know some
people should not own businesses and I'm
one of those people because I you know
take a well you to nice like everyone
wanted to do a set or you just I was a
restaurant
I fed everybody they direct all my booze
and you know and I end of the week I had
nothing I never I was always all the
money and I made on a Sonny and Cher
show which wasn't a whole lot but back
in those days it was substantial but it
was all gone which so why did you want
to open a club what was your thing to
express yourself oh I had nothing doing
the Sonny Churchill was gone although I
did a few other shows I did a series
with Wolfman Jack a series with Lola
Falana the Hudson brothers Bobby Vinton
ended up doing a lot of character actor
work and then when that all folded I was
you know I decided to open up this club
ego you know Wow I got a nightclub and I
got my food and and you don't open up a
club because what I learned
knowing getting to know people like Budd
Friedman who I am I almost became a
piece of his business to be because when
my club folded I had a liquor license
and when Budd Friedman first showed up
in with The Improv here he didn't have
her liquor license for the first few
years the only had a beer
so he asked me if I'd give him my liquor
license and return for a piece of the
improv Wow
I could have made a lot of money my god
I was gonna do that until somebody came
in and bought my club at the last minute
of 5,000 for very little money you know
it was it just kept me out of bank busy
and you just spent the money or was it
was it well it wasn't it wasn't a bad
location was Lankershim in victory and
and it was also I didn't know what I was
doing yeah you know you gotta be it and
and plus you said you'd go on the road
and friends would take it over yeah I
had a few people take take it over and
get into fights and stuff like that a
few times I went out on a few TV shows
it just wasn't certain people shouldn't
be in business and I'm one of them you
know and and there's paperwork there's
bartender stealing from you all this
kind of stuff that goes on and and I've
always said learning from that that you
gotta be in language you gotta be a
prick to be a successful nightclub owner
and most of the ones that go yeah well
it's like landlords or any landlords
good people mom has owned a restaurant
for pre-k but she's tough oh yeah it's
not a nightclub
your mom has right it's a bar I mean a
restaurant and a bar but she she has
savvy she knows not to have people rip
her off she's tough I mean I couldn't be
tough I'm Malika know she is she she has
she and she yeah but it's so yeah
necessarily a negative way but you gotta
be no you gotta be that's your only
thing you're an artist you wanted to do
perform you want to have friends I
always say I special you know what I say
I specialized in bankruptcy and became
very successful but that's what created
the unknown comic you know so yeah tell
this story had that came about well well
yeah what happened is you know when I
lost my ass in the club and I was like
broke penniless again the the gong show
had already been on the air this show
this crazy gong show which is such a big
thing when I was doing stand-up in the
if you're bombing eight scream gong cuz
you'd have all these freaky weird all
these characters and they Gong it when
they wanted you off but it was basically
the first reality show to anybody where
you get on and being in front of a
camera and and so but the thing that
attracted me is if you're in the Union I
heard through the Comedy Store a network
that they had to pay you a lot of guys
were just going on the show figuring out
this dumb guy Jack Gramm and a comedian
did it he did some guys just to get
their white 350 bucks well back then was
less than I was probable 250 I think
back then but so they say even if you
get gong do you get you got to Union
money and I was in Union having done the
Sonny and Cher show and all these shows
so my only thing was I needed a couple
of hundred dollars and I saw on a show
and the woman who was a talent
coordinator I happen to know her name is
still remember Ruth Goldberg because
I've done a bunch of dating games back
then and is that the same thing did you
get Union money Chuck well yeah the
dating Chuck Barris produced that too
you know Chuck Barris produced you know
a lot of comedians did the dating game I
think Schwarzenegger and Herman except
for him yes okay yeah a lot of guys did
if you go back and so so I knew this
woman Ruth Goldberg so I called her up
and I said the Ruth I said can I get on
the gong show I need some you know the
money the Union money and she said yeah
but there's the thing that Chuck does
where he they called curtain closes
where you just come out and you do
something stupid and he closes the
curtain on you she's the one that
suggested that instead of you going on
the show as an act
I said yeah so so that's when I said
well first of all I told right so I
don't anybody recognize me because I did
it on all these TV shows so I said I got
this idea I just put a bag over my head
tell a couple of stupid jokes and nobody
notes me and they won't say oh that's
the guy from the Sonny and Cher show why
is he doing this that would have been
embarrassing knowing the truth right
that I was broke again so what happened
is I went on the first show and you
didn't want to be the guy who's been on
shows just playing the piano and hoping
yes so so I went on and but the the
first joke I told Chuck Barris I went I
still remember I went hey Chucky baby
you and your wife ever make love in the
shower and he said no I said well you
should she loves it loved it and they
all say you're insulting Chuck castle
and and
happened is he liked that vulnerability
that I ended up giving him cuz he was
insulting everybody so all of a sudden
this jerk comes on and insulted the
unknown comic with a bag of your so
right after that so he came running up
to me said can you do another one I like
that you insulted me that was his thing
he was smart enough to realize that so
he said yeah oh yeah sure I thought I
was just gonna make that to her and also
to set it up for Amber was you're you
kind of like what like kind of like what
like Oh running in place and giggling
and had a higher pitched voice
Chucky baby Chucky yeah because no comic
you know most comics use their face to
push over a joke and young on comic
didn't have that luxury so I used to use
my body to push over a joke you know
whatever like a gum biz come out yeah
just at the airport two Muslims trying
to pick me up they thought I was a chick
you know because I had this bag of my so
they would look funny and plus you did
so many with the bag visual puns like
your impression of Linda Blair The
Exorcist and moved around around my
grandfather with a wrinkled bag and then
you brought on a baby like this I
actually brought doll with a bag over it
actually I actually brought my cat on
and let my cat out of the bag and my dog
I had a dog I brought him on with a
completely covered with a bag except for
his head and I said you know you know I
mean except for his tail and I put his
legs through the bag and I said you've
heard of a boxer this is a bagger I was
gonna name him future but beggars can't
be choosers and then there was one where
people were in the audience is my mom
and dad and they had bags it was a crazy
so it really caught on it caught on to a
degree but again I didn't really do
stand-up at that point and then all of a
sudden I'm offered a job in Vegas at the
Sahara hotel I see a nun comic as the
unknown comic they wanted to bring me
there and I had no act so to speak so I
had to like did you have from all your
gong shows like material like piled up
like I'll take this in could you watch
tapes well what I knew because I started
doing stand-up at the various cloud The
Comedy Store and a very the other clubs
but because the unknown comic started to
click and I but what I realized is the
unknown comic in front of an audience
can only work for a certain amount of
time because it then it gets a little
you
especial days I'm learning in the okay
we've seen that and so uh but how long
did you have to do and video at twenty
minutes set in at the Comedy Store
I ended up working like some of the
places and I do like three or four
minutes the other non comic then do you
know 10-15 minutes you take the bag off
yeah and it goes wait as a viewer I
think the first time I saw who Murray
was was the evening at the improv and
was weird because I can see I'm not
Ramadan you guys are not in it right
yeah I love the unknown comment didn't
you take the bag off than just doing
observations yeah yeah so okay so the
live people was it was it like kiss
well they had makeup on and people
wanted to know what you look like no no
people just shocked when I took cuz well
in Vegas I had to do an hour show so
that by then you know they offered me
five grand a week back then which was
like huge money for me it's nothing now
no it isn't now but back then it was
huge money yeah well actually that's
pretty good now come to think of it yeah
but but back then that was like 70
something or yeah that was that was
pretty big money but I didn't make that
for a long time because I had no act so
I hired two girls to be dancers and open
up the show cuz I'm a gangster dancers
yeah they called him the baguettes they
would open up the show I wrote a song
for them you know show me a comic with a
face it's unknown and I'll show you a
brown paper bag
he may be ugly and then maybe he's not
you see it's all just a part of the gag
he's got a million jokes for me it is he
guaranteed to keep you in hilarity he's
original sensational he's one of a kind
he's the unknown and then they would so
my show was I put the show together it
cost me more than the five thousand I
was getting I had to put them in hotels
and I had to hire a band called the
brown baggers who also had bags over
their heads so this whole show was it
was quite and I got fabulous reviews in
Vegas back then but I because I only had
about 15 minutes of material without the
bag I had to really stretch the whole
show out but it ended up working and and
and but it took me years to really
develop as a stand-up still and back in
those days because even when I got that
job I had some horrendous nights because
I just wasn't had experienced as an as a
nightclub comic gihan even even after
owning your
club in getting all the station I never
did stand-up at my club Oh
Ione just catches me and Freeman would
do sketches is that so I'm saying you
know I do like do you like stand-up you
know to this day I can't really figure
it out I'm real when I do it I'm amazed
at how good last gig I did was a couple
years ago I did a I did Reno and I got
standing ovations and waited so you
still do the unknown comic you started
well I do 15 minutes I do an hour show
50 and 12:15 with the bag and then I do
the rest without the bag but the last
guy did in Reno at whatever it is I mean
I got a standing ovation Wow so you
still have to bring all the baguettes
and everyone no no no no I got rid of
that you're trying to show up myself now
you know that but I mean when I started
to get good I realized I need to make
some money you know cause like I said I
I was making zero money back in those
days cuz they which is not good even
back then even back then no because I
had to pay all these yeah so so but it
was uh but it was a growing stage and
it's so you loved it it was like you
Here I am in Vegas except not making
hate thing for me to be honest because
I'm always amazed at some of you know
the guys today that just love gonna you
know Jay Leno you know we talked about
that on this podcast that I wish I could
because man I did five sets I gotta do
Hermosa to me I love expressing myself I
love the book I love this other things
but yeah I don't have that need to be at
a pack club and no I I don't I don't
miss it when I don't do it if somebody
talks about doing it I'll go well I was
looking for it I had this cruise ship
with multi shot memories which they
hired me for at the end of the month for
like good money for six grand for two
shows in there and I had to cancel it
because of this thing I'm going on with
that yeah yeah but that was with Frankie
Avalon and Bobbie right now Shawn on all
these old acts that I I knew we want to
talked about what's going on just a few
stories now there's a story you told me
when I met you and it was in your book
about I don't want to get risque in
front of Mary but you could doesn't
really comprehend okay yeah but Amber's
here but amber doesn't comprehend
hey Mary how are you you did that
No Mary does jokes you won't come here
and tell your joke come here let's tell
her here's Mary likes to dock that's
great who did you write a door well she
didn't write well she writes it now yeah
this is the door that's so self
accepting I love it that's so sweet
that's so she is the greatest little
thing you know I play tennis with you
and you beat me I gotta be honest I was
with the racket by the way yeah I was
playing with Weird Al Yankovic and I was
beating him but then I thought it's
Nicola from me that I'm playing with the
unknown comic and weird al' than them
being with me so then I kind of let them
win a little but then then I wanted to
win and then it was too late ah they
beat me both you he's a nice guy right
very very nice now we talk about people
not nice
now what Annie she just saw Annie last
night yes I know
did you like the dog with the dog on the
show smart or what's the doggies name I
had I have Billy Crystal stories one of
our guests didn't have good things to
say about Teri Garr I shouldn't say that
because she's not doing well
one guy said he would when he worked on
tutsi they weren't nice so when I first
moved to LA I was so excited you know so
nervous I'm at The Improv and Billy
Crystal had seen me he goes he's telling
his friend this guy's funny but he's
sick it's six until you myrrh you gonna
go on I'm going you know you don't get
spots at The Improv when you first moved
there and I go WOW Billy Crystal knows
me and and I go I said I have a demo
tape could I give you my demo tape
because you pushed it Friday
well you know what I had to say about
Billy Crystal in my book did you read
their part or not I read or listened yes
yeah yeah yeah No
was not a I mean I worked with him in in
well my thing about Billy Crystal was
the same thing as my thing about Sonny
Bono I didn't I thought Sonny Bono was a
jerk
besides Billy Crystal and what
differentiates these guys from and most
of the celebrity I've worked with so
many celebrities most of them are really
nice people but Billy Crystal wasn't one
of those nice guys and you always try to
say to yourself okay they did my benefit
a big deal yeah they don't like me it's
not my problem but then you find out
later but my thing with Billy Crystal
and and and Sonny Bono who I spent four
and a half years is they don't want to
associate with you unless you're at
their level or above and Amber's the
same way oh please but that's and
there's a few other people I've met like
that and that's that's not nice you know
and that's what that's when I worked on
a show in Canada with him we were doing
a show and I tried to hey how you doing
and he just like looked at me like
please you know I have better people to
talk to you know and then I met him
again at the improv and say remember we
worked in Canada and he went tell tell
about the time that you did the casting
give him a gift what was that story
oh that's Sonny Bono yes yeah Sonny but
was the same way I mean you know you
work with a guy four and a half years
and he just tweeted well he called the
regulars including you know Terry on the
show he referred to us as atmosphere oh
where was atmosphere yeah and see the
thing that they Chris beard and and and
and Alan blye who produced like I said
who were on laughs and they produced
also The Smothers Brothers show before
they they produced a Sonny and Cher
they learned something from late to
Carol Burnett Show don't give everybody
big billing like the regulars will go to
their head they good won't things though
they want more money if you get so you
just called
so let's plays atmosphere yeah so no
well that wasn't Sonny Bono but the
producers so we we didn't have open
billing on the show like The Carol
Burnett Show yeah also I sit around
I always at the end of the show also on
the show was Marie Langston framing
hanging tens dealer that's the only kind
of billing we got but they did that
purposely
so that if we had up from billing and
people got to know us but Sonny know
that was a different issue he just just
treated us like we were not at his level
and referred to his atmosphere so one
time share is having a birthday party
for what was she like real quick share
was uh I liked her back then you know
she was the problem with chair was she
was very young when she made it you know
when you make it you're like 19 skinny
or 16 17 she had her first right
half-breed I remember some of the song
those came later but the Sonny and Cher
show or something yeah I got you babe I
think I was 16 or 17 so when you make it
that big you know your brain hasn't
fully adjusted so and I have this theory
and that's whether it's with Elvis or
Jerry Lewis and you met Elvis yeah party
with him these these would with these
guys they're braying at 16 or 17 when
you're that famous you don't really
fully grasp that you're lucky you really
think you're something special
and I think that was a little bit of
shared too she thought she was something
special working on I liked a terrific
sense of humor and I could tell the
story about that
one day I was the werewolf every every
Halloween right so the first Halloween
they asked me beautiful so they I spent
like two hours in the makeup chair
getting all this hair on my face and on
my hands and fingers grotesque hairy
nails and so so after I'm all made up I
go into the dressing or the rehearsal
hall and I see cher his back is toward
me she's talking to one of the dancers
so I think I'm gonna scare her right so
I sneak up behind her and I put this
ugly grotesque hairy hand on her
shoulder and she just looked at my hand
and goes Sunday your mother's here whoa
very quick said to her and we got along
really good back in those days and and I
think she's and even after the years see
I've run in there and shames in in Vegas
and we hang out or made it happy you
ended up I'm sorry and
she did a little bit of a Vegas career
kept going yeah journals years when I
was doing Vegas and and but what
happened is when Sonny died and and the
first interviewer called me from some
newspaper and I went and I was a little
shocked idea what do you think of Sonny
oh yeah good guy and I went why am i
lying I didn't like
so then they did a special when he
called us the documentary on sunny right
and then they came to me and I said but
I'm gonna tell the truth
and I told the truth on the document
that I thought he was you know I just
told on the documented what I didn't
that I didn't think very much I'm faced
with what I just said to you guys and I
guessed Harry gonna you know what I
tried it you know what I try to say to
be diplomatic I go he's not an
exceptional guy yeah one thing I say to
people I want to say go and that's
saying you're an [ __ ] but you're more
of that then you're not that's very good
yeah but I think Sears to have had and
at some point you know even though she
wrote horrible stuff when they broke up
and and and all of a sudden after that
she felt bad he got killed yeah yeah but
she loved him even though he probably
was abusive or something he was
apparently yeah to her a lot of ways
yeah manipulated her about the coup
maybe it's a short syndrome he was a
short guy she was tall it got to be the
boss that he mate was a mayor and stuff
yeah it's yeah so that was I get into a
fist bump when he died like yes no I
mean I'm I you feel bad about anybody
dying sure yeah yeah but he what he
skied he skied into a mouth a little let
it go Fred I thought you might be some
language into a tree right and that same
week was one of the Kennedys
yeah skied into a tree stand is so I
said you know it's it's odd that because
celebrities usually die in trees you
know is that what they say they die in
trees there should have been one more
amber you're from Colorado you a skier
yeah I did was never done it really no
no I might that would be where was I was
I was at Whistler I did a this sounds
like an oxymoron or a up I did a bad ski
movie called downhill Willie and
Whistler it was that was a porn I did
downhill yeah yeah that that's before
viagra
and so we run slopes but I've never I've
never skied I think I would fall but is
it that danger why can they just take
trees away I said that dangerous you're
right I never liked me it was just cold
I like I'd rather live it's really fun
but it's three hours of getting ready
for a ten minute ride down there really
I went on a ski lift which was fun well
not me I'm afraid of heights
really I was little they didn't have
that little crossbar oh my you were
little when she was younger
oh yeah I am I yes skiing I I can't see
that movie to walk i i'm not its height
i'll picture i don't see ever as that
yeah i'll picture being on a place
there's no pleasing the picture like
hanging from the clock at the grove and
the antenna and I get dizzy like I
picture being in places well I'll
picture a neighborhood and be depressed
that I lived there when I don't you know
so I pictured things I don't have the
picture okay when I'm hiking I picture
like a rock falling from the sky like
I'm like on a lower point like if
there's a mountain or a hill I'm like oh
I bet you a boulder is gonna come fly at
my head in decapitate me buddy I can't I
can't see that Trade Center movie the
walk I did it lame joke on Twitter she's
great on Twitter that I got dizzy seeing
the walk as I sat on the top the top
seat I cut you know did you see it no I
I thought I think I there's a thing in
Toronto there's it isn't Toronto now
you've done a lot of shows in Toronto
but they have a thing where it's like
the X World Trade Center one of the
biggest things you're all the way at the
top but it's a glass thing you walk over
and see
that freaked me out walking you gotta
cross bridges where you walk over a
break from building the building
no I can't do that stuff oh my god yeah
so he tell a story about when you met a
woman he did something he met women and
had sex I had to say with without your
celebrity status and one in Vegas where
the commercial came on or do you think
commercial charity oh all the chair oh
yeah that was such a wonderful little
story but that's when I had I asked I
was riding high I was I honed the
rolls-royce you know long wheelbase so
it's like a limo and I was like riding
high and working in Vegas and so so so I
got my rolls-royce parked in front of
Sahara hotel and so one day I come out
after a show and I see this girl on the
side crying and I said you know I said
hi how you doing what's wrong and she's
uh I came here from I think Bakersfield
somewhere like that with my girlfriend
and then we we showed up we went
gambling lost all our money but she's
still in there and then she's all angry
and and I I haven't seen Vegas or
anything and bla bla she's going on on
this upset so I thought man she was
attractive you know so I thought well
you know no no that was not my plan for
the first five or six seconds no no I
was actually legitimate I felt bad for
her and I said in and I I said you want
I'll take you on a tour Las Vegas
something down the strip at a strip if
you'd like and she said really so so she
somehow thought I was the parking
attendant and that's you know that I was
the parking guy cuz I was just in like
you know torn jeans and stuff like that
so but I mean I was just a so anyway I
so I said yeah I'll take it in the roll
so she thought I was like was in your
room she's know was mine so I put her in
the backseat it was like a
long-wheelbase and I take her nice take
her up and down the strip showing her
this hotel and that hotel and all the
way around there and then as I'm talking
I went well you know she's she might be
fun to you know hang out with if she's
interested and III owned a home in Vegas
real nice home with pool and everything
and I and
so eventually you got rid of the Bant
the baguettes and started making more
money obviously with the pool meaning
you were making money
oh I'll know that by then I was I was
well by then I had already had my own
shows in Vegas I think I was like
headlining at the Tropicana and the
landmark and and I had and I had a bunch
of people opening for me I had you know
I had like you know George Miller and
all these guys were Willie Tyler and
Lester and there's Jakov Smirnoff all
Scheuer all these guy Elayne Boosler
they were all opening for me back in
those days I was oh and I have a record
you know they have all these comedy
clubs in Vegas I'm the first one they
ever put a comedy an old comedy show in
Las Vegas first person yes he I read in
your book that at the Landmark Hotel did
the the it was always headliners were
you the first one to have it like a
comedy club like three people and one
show and it was me and Roger and Roger
and Elaine Boosler was the first show I
ever put together in Las Vegas and so
that was and and I have the write up
says Marie likes this putting the first
all comedy show in Las Vegas at the
Landmark Hotel so I'm the first one when
a woman was on it good for you Elaine
one who's one of the funniest very very
I see that we grew up in the same black
sheeps at bay she's a few years older
than me yeah we have the same kind of
crazy mothers yeah I went to my high
school Larry David went to my high
school and Donna peskow he's serious
yeah she was at a high school in
Brooklyn
but I say it was it was you know so that
was a great period so so anyway I said
you know you want to have a drink at my
place I have a you know place down the
street a little house and she oh you
won't get any trouble you know she's
thinking and I'll call down in and and
you know no I said I already let them
know I made some story up you know I was
sort of a so why were you going with the
thing that you're at a parking attendant
with this work why just we're not went
with it because she accepted it Oh to
preface the story I should tell you that
I had done it well two things I was
going to do a radio show the next
morning I had to go do some radio show
forget his name that hosted it and also
I had done a commercial in Las Vegas for
hard to adopt kids
and I would come out as young comics say
hey I'm no comic there's a lot of kids
are hard to adopt and I had like all
these little bags like one with a black
bag one with slanted eyes you know asian
bag well but all these little bags and I
did that but so he is a sweet guy I know
amber doesn't like him I could tell I'm
just kidding but you've mentored
mentally challenged people yeah that's
why it's great that he's done this work
he's a great guy when I start on the
Sonny and Cher show I figure I had to
get back so I used to work with mentally
challenged people yeah so having her was
was perfect for me but so anyway so so I
did and then after about 10 seconds of
that or 20 seconds it was a minute
commercial I take off the bag and I go
ahead no seriously this Marine Langston
and if there's all these kids are hard
to top and you should do your best it
was a local commercial in Vegas today I
get this woman at my house and we're
drinking and we're having a good time
next thing we know were doing stuff that
I only read about very embarrassed ya
know I didn't I fought every many tries
so anyway we did do that so afterwards
we were laying in bed and we're having a
good time and the TV's on and all of a
sudden this commercial comes on and and
she still doesn't know and have a clue
and I didn't know you know cuz I never
really even to this day I never tell
people you ever heard of the unknown
comic it's just that's me ya know I just
don't do that and I mean when people I'm
with say oh you know he's really
irritates me I just don't do that so
anyway the this commercial comes on and
she jumps up oh it's you know comic you
know she's watched it see oh I love that
guy he's Sophia but she's going on and
I've watched him on the Conklin and now
I'm going oh he's gonna take the bag off
and she's raving or his guy oh he's
gonna take the bag off it and the guy
takes the bag off of the TV she looks at
the guy and does the best triple take
you've ever ha she went you know just
back and forth like okay with it oh yeah
yeah and then and then the next morning
and so next morning I had to do this TV
show so they sent to those radio show no
it was a TV show so they sent this limo
and I so I I let her
I said so she went with me and they and
I they took her from the TV show back to
her hotel in the limo and she just said
this is gonna be one of the greatest
memories of my life so it was really
really terrific in that but I just never
got her her name
sad Wow so I want to ask you now
basically also you have a daughter I
think she was a Britney Spears
background singer like I told you the
funny thing is she's been like following
in my sort of showbiz foots it's so hard
for people to grow up with that and not
want Bobby Slayton comedian his daughter
is a backup singer for pitbull whatever
that really big big yes I'm an old guy
he's a big rapper yeah Maya yeah I'm I I
i I've talked a bit sorry let's try to
find it and also he got cursed out by
Frank Sinatra's another good story he
cursed him a threatened to kill him
threat to have me on my legs broken and
all that well yeah I guess he was yeah
that's actually pretty funny funny story
cuz I had no clue you who would think
that Frank Sinatra would call you on the
phone and start cursing so he called
laughing and asked for your number
well don't know make me laugh me laugh
that's it
but amber they used to be a show called
make me laugh and they brought it back
with comedians you'd sit there and with
your arms folded and you win money if
you don't laugh so you did it it's the
unknown I heard they in fact I was
talking to Danny Johnson he said they
tried to bring that back well they tried
bring it back I actually I had a
actually brought it back on Comedy
Central Marc Cohn hosted it and ice
already quit doing stand-up and you get
an you get $500 so I came on and did my
jokes i from a million years and and
they they won money yeah yeah yeah she
I want co-wrote her with her boyfriend
name and it's her singing no it's a she
wrote it she used to sing and interact
that was one of her songs with his
Korean girl who was like you ever heard
of a group called Girls Generation do
you know how to do well tell us about
your daughter she was a singer and the
backup and now she's a writer
well she no she started out becoming a
wanting to be a writer she her big dream
was to write a song for Britney Spears
and and her last album when she finally
got us home on her album but the Britney
she's doing was a bomb-dog knows he
he'll do well off this song she didn't
do that great off Britney's album she
sang background and and they really
didn't pay her very well I want to tell
if if people listening to this and well
if you go to the artist ttae Yeo n
tae-yong if you go on to her on youtube
now I shared now you're going through a
thing could we talk about it okay cuz I
would like to try to help your GoFundMe
if anyone's listening I know it's hard
to talk about it now okay we don't have
to yeah okay I'm just excited that
hopefully next week does this horrible
nightmare nightmare will be over and it
looks like but I went with you know I'm
with you know Laurie air overhead
daughter her daughter Lisa bloom we'll
put it we'll put the link on the thing
yeah so basically it's a really it's a
great video but basically this song you
know they have be number one in 8 or 10
countries and have 16 million views
already in a week on YouTube it's it's
huge in the in the overall marketplace
so now with Mary adidas your other
daughter do you both take care of Mary
or do you love to head know whatever
she's she's with me a hundred percent of
the time yeah and and hopefully after
next weeks you'll be permanently as a
primary yeah thing it's been a it's been
a tough battle anybody's been through a
court buy whole especially with a kid
with with special needs but she she just
really needs to be with me right we
don't have to talk about it but I'm
gonna put on the thing your go fund me
you can't but it's not a big deal you
know I mean
I'm grateful that you supported in any
way III put money and I put it on my
Facebook and I saw people shared it yeah
yeah and she just loves you to death she
just you can't sit away from Daddy for I
mean it's just something I admit not
having children you can't even
articulate I can't I could think I know
what the bond is like but until you have
it know you can't describe and it's
interesting cuz when I you know I have
my older daughter and that was all great
and like my oldest she's amazing I mean
she just turned 26 but she she doesn't
do drugs she doesn't smoke she doesn't
sounds like what are you GI
corny jokes don't curse I don't smoke I
don't drink oh damn I left my cigarettes
at the bar no she doesn't smoke doesn't
drink she's always a designated driver
and doesn't do drugs she has had eleven
abortions so there's always that was
that one thing is that one little thing
that that is no she doesn't she's just a
great kid she's amazing she's been with
her boyfriend who's also
co-writes with her and producers for ten
years i fact I introduced him when they
were both like 15 Wow and his felt
together and they're still they well
they were they were friends for about
four or five years I've never from like
eleven as some canola fifteen and before
they became a relationship so I mean to
be friends with somebody for four or
five years that's and they're gonna be
together for good but he's half black
that sort of pisses me off yeah me too
ya know a night they actually came and
saw me one time in Vegas a few years ago
what she was with him she brought him in
and I introduced her off from the stage
and I said and I said there's her
boyfriend I went wait a minute is he
half black you know do this from the
stage and she said oh I remember yeah
she did tell me he's half black but
she's pissed because it's the top half
now you uh know I'm as liberal I are you
know no I mean I remember you just yeah
no I listen to your I go back well even
with Freeman King my first partner was
black going way back oh and by the way
we did an album back then where one of
the cuts is the first black president
I interviewed him Wow like science
fiction yeah and who would have known
but Freeman died a few years ago he
never got that but I used to tell my
daughter I said you can never be
prejudiced because Freeman introduced me
to her mother
so I said because you wouldn't be around
if it wasn't for a black guy you know
who introduced me to her mother yes no
no I it's altered is interesting amber
in that your parents never hugged you
said they loved you
and someone I teach you how to do that
well showbusiness taught me how to do
that and plus a friend in yeah in Vegas
no it's true my parents but see what as
I grew up Boulder well you know I found
out my mother was raised in an orphanage
so she never had anybody touch her love
her and my father was the left home ran
away when he was like 13 by a very mean
they were still proud of you know the
thing is about my parents is they never
touched us or told us they loved us but
you knew that they loved you see this is
weird because it for some reason we
don't know how our brains develop why we
think when we know that it did bother
some of my siblings and who were
confused and blamed my parents a lot but
and that never ever bothered me and and
so they were loving they just didn't
demonstrate they weren't they put you
down and I and when I first came to
Hollywood when people would hug me I
would like free and I still do something
I flinch when people walk by
yeah but I came the opposite thanks to a
really my dearest friend who died two
years ago in Vegas are known for 40
years who was one of the most loving him
and his wife but he especially you know
if he loved you he told you and he
hugged you and he became like one of my
best he he was my best friend and it was
terrible loss to me but but he's the one
that really taught me plus show Pete
show business people a lot of fake
Hawking when you go yeah but when I did
the plays and it's not bad you know so
yeah we're your parents kept like when
you walk through the door they're like
hey that was their tone nice or were
they strict or how did you know for sure
why weren't you filled with fear well my
dad was it was a crippled so he had a
hard time working his entire life so you
know that was a whole ship thing but a
good thing he couldn't chase me you know
if he was angry at me but and my mother
was one of the first she worked because
my dad couldn't work so my mother worked
in a factory all the time and so is a
varied you know day it was a very tough
upbringing with my parents but I knew I
never ever doubted that they they
weren't negative they didn't put you
down no never no in fact my dad I have
that hand no hugging
oh really no my dad wanted me to get
into electronics cuz he one day so I'm
gonna learn how to fix radios and I said
no I like chill businesses oh you got to
do what you got to do you know and and
my mother was just she was like a saint
all my entire life she just worked hard
and and and you again you felt that she
loved Oh interesting sorry my sister who
resented it one time she said I you know
she was upset I said look I'm gonna call
dad this is a long time ago get him on
the phone and you got to tell him what
you feel so I call my father in Montreal
you know and my sister was up here and I
said dad and that's mad because you
never you know you guys never told us
you love us or hugged us you know and he
said whoa she's crazy and I had a runny
nose a net you Larry I love you she went
what and she just started blur and from
that point on that's all it took every
time he talked to any of us
he did it all it took was that one
little converse my mother on the other
hand she uh I love you mom oh yeah me
too me too
she could never get it out uh except
toward the end she managed but it just
was not there you gotta imagine being
raised in an orphanage where nobody
nobody loved you and it just it it was
it's very wise of you to take that
approach sort of having empathy and
putting yourself in their shoes as
opposed to taking resentment yeah again
I don't know I never wanted kids
you know but when they happen I went
holy crap I just love this and you don't
know where it comes from I retired when
my older daughter I mean it just I
raised her you know and pretty much as a
single dad and just went wow this is
great
even though there's a lot of hardships
and raising a kid but I never thought of
it as a negative thing and when she was
born with Down syndrome I mean I went
you be why what do you mean because my
philosophy in life is that change is
growth when you have change in your life
you can't help but
because me paekche Oprah says problems
the solution - I remember it again about
heaven
thinks he knows I was I was like
diamonds in his glass yeah I don't buy
into him but he said one thing because I
went through a lawsuit that was so
killing for like nine months and
prompted the solutions are in problems
there's an opportunity in disguise
I like that but you don't look at his
problem so oh no I never looked at his
problem like I said to me if she would
have been a normal kid it would have
been oh I'm gonna go through the same
experiences but having her is a whole
new series of experiences with her and I
just love that kid I love her too yeah
so you have the best dad in the world
[Music]
the luckiest girl marry lucky so you
don't know handy manny tools that talk
you know she only she doesn't like she
doesn't like even cartoons words cartoon
characters sing she only loves anything
that sings like found a music live
live-action people The Wiggles Hannam
Barney where all the kids sing she loves
anything that sings and she sings these
things karaoke not to get personal but
when you said retired so is it just but
the situation like like harrowing like
financially or just no okay what you
mean about finance you know cuz you're
in a happy with the financial thing yeah
yeah yeah but you're right meaning yeah
I was I was fine but you know I'm
retired I'm 71 you know I live off
Social Security and and in in pension I
have a pension from after so those two
things kept me going but then there's a
whole other story yeah this is there's a
whole other story where this woman ended
up legally this is why this whole court
case I had to go inward she from her 16
years ago
somehow filed a court order without me
knowing it illegally done where I ended
up owing her four hundred thousand
dollars in back child support for her
and it's a reason I had to cancel that
cruise because I can't get a passport
because of owing $400,000 so you're
fighting that oh yeah it's a huge but
it's already established that the the
judge is gonna overturn it because it
was this I can't really I should sure
but if she did a lot of frogs to fight
that or is it custody oh she's no
there's two things there's two things
that involved so also the custody thing
is there but this was another whole
separate issue which I got blindsided
with I mean never had a problem in 16
years all of a sudden went to the office
and and I got blindsided
but luckily I've already been told the
judges seize and then when when will we
know if there's peace when you could
move on when will we know
next Friday hopefully the worst thing
for a guy is this woman three four weeks
ago took me or went to the police saying
I molested
well that's bogus
and that was that was to be it well no
one took it with any grain of salt or
anything no hopefully that will fall
back fire but that was insane behavior
that's documented that you can it's not
documented but there's a history yeah so
anyway that again your time a blessing
in disguise that incident may be a
blessing in disguise because that that's
the one thing the judge may go what the
hell cuz yeah there's absolutely well I
like the officer that she went to they
they didn't buy it and you know I really
bothers me because somebody do that it's
just it just so it really bothers me
well two things first of all when we
talking about I love you saying that how
people are married and in love and they
go from I love you to these vicious
accusations and divorces how did it get
from kissing I love you who are gonna be
with you forever to that craziness and
also I've heard about this a lot where
they throw it's like
throwing at the racecar throwing out the
molestation card like it just someone
ate him throw that out that's what's
funny is I told my daughter Maya six
eight months ago I said I'm surprised
she hasn't thrown that out I mean I told
her that so and she should had no dad
she would never do that you know and I M
so you can imagine how shocked she was
when she threw that car and I was like
blonde or I'm brought in and you know
that we got a tape you and for an hour
they interview me and if you do you have
a lawyer with you or no that's why I got
rid of that lawyer I mean I I call that
Lauren and he wouldn't he wouldn't
return my calls and then and then
finally he texted a secretary tell them
to go to their thing for days that guy
wouldn't call me so you got two things
going on that hundred thousand and this
and that and the custody so three things
oh my god Marie I am I am I put the
thing on and I saw that the love you
have or people giving anything they can
and one person gave seven thousand Ruth
Buzzi they're like yeah well they're
godparents to both my daughters Ruth
Buzzi I never heard it was buzzy you're
too young yeah no she was on laughing
and it was very very famous at one time
yeah any everyone from laughing was
really famous I know Jo Anne Worley from
Fred Willard parties so how well what's
his name
Bernie Schwartz was not famous from
laughs how do you wax it Bernie Schwartz
isn't that Tony Curtis his real name
maybe something like that I was gonna
maybe I'll answer my own question how do
you deal with these soul-killing stress
I guess answered my own question is just
you're with her and you it's a love is
just right yeah but right now I you know
I I don't get her as much as I I should
have her and that's what we're fighting
for two of them Wow well like I said
that that whole thing may turn out
probably will turn out to be a blessing
in disguise and and again um
you again I know you not as well as some
of these other people like Johnny dark
but you know
the sweetness exuding and you're just a
seminal part of people's childhoods and
and just all those people are one guy
who listens al claw
we'll get mad if I don't mention he
loves Kip a daughter like with me you
like kippa daughter is he a crazy girl I
started out with Kip but yeah I got it
you're in outs with him I was em on the
outs but I've seen the other side of him
maybe once too often you know what I
mean hey Kip how's it going get my hug
you're one of these guys that I can't
picture anyone saying anything bad about
Murray
except for Sonny Terry card no Sonny
didn't realize he you know but I'm just
saying oh no I don't even think Billy
Crystal knows what a dick you know
except for being corny which I get a
kick out of Twitter it's just these if
you follow my Twitter you'll get a lot
of us jokes something old something new
something borrowed something blue is
what I call my Twitter feed you know I
just you know throw everything out there
basically and people think you know or
Facebook that I do I don't do that stuff
for them I just do it for me keep my
brain where have fun you have fun with
it ya know if people are listening
please support Murray with his audiobook
what's it called again I I just
downloaded and been listening no journey
through the unknown journey to the
unknown where it is um it's on Amazon
it's my life story from the day I was
born till until last year yes it's just
great stories about Sinatra and Jerry
Lewis and Mickey Rooney and Elvis and
I'm gonna put the GoFundMe thing on
there you know was weird last night I
walk into an e with Mary you know we had
to walk down Vine Street and all those
stars and I started walking over them
and I said yeah on the way to it was a
bullet block and a half to the theater
now let me see how many of these people
I know or worked with it was like almost
every other star was so I want to say
you or worked with it was like freaky
even with this a nightmare
you have to say and you said in your
book you've had a great life the this is
the worst period of my life this period
but I'm still and I'm able I'm a very
optimistic person but has it stressed me
out yeah but overall my life has been so
great and it still continues to be great
because that little creep over there
then I love how much to Daddy love you
big time married did you have fun
listing and hanging out Mary you know
I'm gonna try to get you tickets for
plays I used to know people I worked at
the ages musical is what I'm gonna I'm
gonna really look at yes you love
musicals huh I wish I would have seen
that they had Matilda the musical about
a few months ago I she loves she loves
Matilda - I'm going to yeah Mattel she's
you know a lot of times into her but her
favorite TV show I think is still Sex in
the City she has that wow again
Rizzo she's so happy rapping I'm so glad
you made this trip I was bugging you cuz
I just again you have again I'm being
repetitious the 70s does the shows I
love to Mary Tyler Moore all those
people a gong show like I said Mary
Hartman Fred Willard they're all part of
that specialness of my life yeah well
and then getting to meet you yeah like
when I got to meet Jack Riley from the
Bob Newhart show and you see the sweet
people Oh Jackie says he's got problems
yeah oh okay I know we're wrapping up
but before we wrap up I just want to say
he did a movie he wrote called night
Patrol one of my first crushes was Linda
Blair and Eve plumb from the Brady Bunch
so I think I even asked you I see she
got you when we played Tennessee oh yeah
she can't find the right guy Linda Blair
ago I was had a question ago she's not
she likes the bad boys yeah she's but
she's never been married you know we're
like best buddies we've been best
buddies for many many years
you know the Exorcist Linda Blair yeah
Linda Blair yeah she's this I've noticed
eh animal activists yeah I write about
her in the book a lot too cuz I owe ya
big animal activist and ya know she's
still single looks great you had to hook
up with her now let me not but you said
she likes the way Rick Springfield
that's what she likes
that's she was with him and Rick James
she likes Rick's maybe so change your
name to Rick yeah if I was I could think
of a celebrity with a Rick give me a
Rick of threes yeah way into my mo she
did up your alley with me in night
Patrol oh this so many things we didn't
get to yeah yeah yeah you are one less
keep saying that he's responsible for a
centerfold being murdered because he was
making out with her and then the husband
got jealous okay I mean I'm exaggerated
a little but Dorothy stratten Oh
Dorothy's fat no yeah from noticing a
movie star 80 I've never heard of
Dorothy stratten she was a Playboy
centerfold that got murdered by her
jealous husband in the movie you said no
not really no but he was getting jealous
and oh yeah no no I did a movie Patrick
Swayze's first movie by the way
you remember Patrick Swayze member
Britney Spears no no but Patrick
Swayze's first movie was a rollerskating
movie called skate town USA his for you
Maria the unknown comic I was both
actually I didn't own comic onstage and
then I was Marie I played a drunk but a
whole bunch of comics did it that big
dumb laugh Denny Johnston Gary mule deer
a whole bunch of comics were in this
movie but as Patrick Swayze's first
movie and there's Dorothy stratten who
was just absolutely gorgeous Johnny dark
he'll talk to you because he did the
movie too and we would go to dailies and
he just was he was so in love with her
so she doesn't move anyway I had to do a
scene where I pinched her but in the
movie you know so I got up in and then I
kept doing it wrong you know I got her
too low that was younger and but her
boyfriend was there and Eric Roberts
played the guy he kept star 80 and I
obviously I flirted she saw I can't talk
I can't talk you know he my boyfriend's
over there all right you know she seemed
really scared and to know like months
later he brutally murdered her and is
jealous because he was jealous of her
yeah Wow
yeah but she was there such a sweetheart
on the movie but yeah that was amazing
yeah Flip Wilson wasn't it a couple of
guys from the Kotter series where Ron
Palillo who played horse Jack yeah yeah
didn't he pass out yeah he did he did
yeah I am wrapping up thank you so much
I know you traveled far and I really
really were going to get this up next
week and hope for people donate any yeah
well I'm
I'm really glad I've been I've been
wanting to do this you know it's just
I've been rocking fusing yeah yeah it's
hard because he's always going to court
cases yeah well we'll do it another time
when this yes let's let's have the good
news you bring up all the other stuff
yes more jokes it will be funnier no
you're funny as hell you know we'll do
Mary why don't we do this amber why
don't we when this is all over we're
gonna have some fun musical theater
people here that's a good idea
what could get some people like from
Annie I know yes she'll sing what's your
favorite song she'll sing a song well if
we put a little music on here I mean
it's yes let's do that what in the hairy
monkey on a cruise ship we're crazy
that's a good idea
you like tomorrow right tomorrow she
could sing tomorrow or a sign will come
out it's a hard-knock life for us yeah I
was so dick won't that be fun amber will
sing with Mary we're gonna bring it back
again Marie thank you so much I'm gonna
do it I love you uh-oh I know I love you
too all right though I marry to the best
Thank You amber and oh that's her name I
forgot oh yeah and please see your horn
Barstow right yeah where please support
this podcast I'm rated subscribe thank
you very much thank you